ich dachte ich habe im leben versagt das
nur ein kompletter verlierer in einem
band lebt
sein zuhause ist die wildnis von west
amerika seine wohnung ein umgebauter
krankenwagen rob wells ist moderner
nomade seit mehr als 25 jahren am anfang
eine große herausforderung
ich war dazu gezwungen ich wollte es
nicht tun ich hatte gerade eine
scheidung hinter mir und die hälfte
meines gehalts ging meine ex-frau um sie
und die kinder zu unterstützen
was für mich übrig blieb davon konnte
ich keine wohnung mieten ich habe in
anchorage alaska gelebt was sehr teuer
ist ich wusste also buchstäblich nicht
wo ich leben sollte
er ist unterwegs im norden origins
schlägt sein lager für die nächsten tage
auf im sommer kommt er gerne hierher in
die schattigen bilder viel braucht er
nicht sein wagen hat keine dusche kein
badezimmer alles muss auf sieben
quadratmeter passen
ich habe ein schlafzimmer ein büro und
auf dieser seite ist meine garderobe ich
zeige euch mein unordentliches haus es
hat vorhänge weil es so unordentlich ist
alle meine klamotten bürokram hier habe
ich bücher das ist ein bücherregal
in den usa leben zwischen einer und drei
millionen menschen in ihren fahrzeugen
schätzungen nomaden zu zählen ist
schwierig bob bringt sie einmal pro jahr
zusammen bei einer art festival für
nomaden manche sind freiwillig auf der
straße viele weil sie ihre miete nicht
mehr zahlen könnten und es könnten noch
viel mehr werden
wir kümmern uns immer weniger um die
soziale sicherheit der menschen in
diesem land wir kümmern uns nur um die
reichen geben ihnen immer mehr geld
und jetzt nach corona mit den
zwangsräumungen die wieder in gang
gekommen sind wollen sie diese leute
rausschmeißen und die mieten
das thema frustriert bob ein corona
schutz für säumige mieter innen läuft im
herbst aus 3,6 millionen menschen in den
usa sind dann von zwangsräumungen
bedroht
schicksale denen chloe seinen film
gewidmet hat ausgezeichnet mit sechs
oscars die personen im film mehr als nur
schauspieler innen menschen aus dem
wahren leben auch bob ist mit dabei im
mittelpunkt eine frau die für so viele
steht sie verliert ihre arbeit muss ihr
haus verkaufen um zu überleben nimmt sie
gelegenheitsjobs an
mammoth lakes kalifornien hier am rande
der sierra nevada zwischen bergen und
pinienwäldern kempens l und rebecca
salahuddin sie wohnen nicht nur auf dem
campingplatz sondern arbeiten auch hier
ein typischer job für nomaden 35 stunden
pro woche sie aber haben sich dieses
leben ausgesucht
wir wollen heute vom täglichen trott
aufstehen zur arbeit gehen nach hause
kommen schlafen gehen wir waren damals
beide bei der polizei und in diesem
beruf hatten wir glück wenn wir einen
tag in der woche frei hatten ich war
kriminalpolizisten hatte ziemlich oft
rufbereitschaft vier stunden schlaf pro
nacht bahn stand
selber beim militär bekommt daher eine
kleine rente und krankenversicherung
sicherheiten wie viele nomaden nicht
haben ganz ohne arbeit aber geht es auch
bei ihnen nicht das war ihnen klar als
sie irgendwann kündigten ihr haus
verkaufen und vor drei jahren komplett
in den wohnwagen zogen den campingplatz
in ordnung halten das macht ihnen spaß
doch im winter steht wieder arbeiten im
warenlager bei amazon an
die arbeit bei amazon ist ein sehr
monoton es ist alles detailliert
vorgegebenen die zeit wird berechnet und
dinge die sie tun würden von denen sie
denken dass sie für einen menschen
normal wäre wie die toilette zu benutzen
oder eine pause zu machen sich kurz die
beine zu vertreten
diese dinge sind bei diesen job nicht
möglich man ist immer in eile
amazon hat erkannt dass es sich bei den
nomaden um eine fast unerschöpfliche
zahl von saison arbeiter innen handelt
vor einigen jahren wurde das programm
kemper fonds geschaffen schuften für 11
dollar 50 die stunde mindestens zehn
stunden am tag um im winter das
weihnachtsgeschäft zu bewerkstelligen
mehrere tausend nomaden machen laut
amazon bei dem programm mit das ist der
preis den sie für die freiheit zahlen
müssen
wenn die veiling arbeitet schon seit 40
jahren nicht mehr lebt seitdem in seinem
wohnwagen
auf wenig raum
minimalistisch aber genau so wie er es
mag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist mein badezimmer ich habe einen
schreibtisch an der toilette weil ich
gerne dort sitze und lese
so kann man ihn runter klaren und dort
drüben ein stapel bücher das sollte mir
peinlich sein ist es aber nicht
auf handys zu do liste steht heute nicht
mehr viel er hat in seinem leben nur
vier jahre gearbeitet hatte damals einen
plan in kurzer zeit genug verdienen um
den rest seines lebens nicht mehr
arbeiten zu müssen
geld ist enorm wichtig besonders wenn
man versteht dass es freiheit erkaufen
kann
und man nicht annähernd so viel davon
braucht wie man denkt das ist der kern
meiner botschaft dieser lebensstil
kostet mich durchschnittlich nur 600
dollar im monat
viel geld ist randy nicht wichtig
gemeinschaft aber schon deshalb hat er
eine gruppe gegründet die zeitweise
zusammenreißt was sie gerade beschäftigt
besprechen sie in einer morgenrunde und
12 uhr früh aufstehen muss hier niemand
wir mögen es sehr mit menschen in
kontakt zu sein wir sind lange allein
gereist aber die gemeinschaft hilft ein
besserer mensch zu werden und neue dinge
zu entdecken
sie alle sind aussteiger müssen so nicht
leben sondern haben sich bewusst dafür
entschieden mit dabei auf die deutschen
ariane abler und michael ertl sie reisen
seit zehn jahren durch die usa hatten
genug geld gespart um sich dieses leben
leisten zu können auch sie sind froh um
die gemeinschaft von handys gruppe
also was mir aufgefallen ist gerade so
die freunde in deutschland
dass man sich auseinander lebt und ich
finde es dann schwer so zu sagen
freunde in deutschland zu halten weil
irgendwie
wenn man unterwegs ist lernt man andere
leute kennen die dasselbe lieben lieben
und mit denen kann man das leben teilen
die verstehen worüber man spricht das
denke ich ist ähnlich wie wenn man den
nachbarschaft hat zu hause nur sind halt
nicht immer alle nachbarn gleichzeitig
hier
man hilft sich bewältigt die
herausforderungen des alltags gemeinsam
denn das nomadenleben kann auch mal
nerven setzt wenn es frei gewählt ist
ganz klar die sache an die normale
mensch gar nicht denkt er sozusagen
zuhause ist ein wasserhahn aufdreht und
auf die toilette geht das sind so sachen
wie waffeln wir unser wassertank auf wo
wird man das abwasser los wo geht man
einkaufen und wenn man das eben
permanent immer immer immer wieder hat
dann denken wir sie schon was soll der
mist eigentlich aber dann sitzt man hier
in so schönen flecken und denkt sich ja
genau deshalb mache ich das eigentlich
schöne flecken wie dieser hier colorado
mitten in den rocky mountains
orte an die man nur mit dem camper kommt
aber ran wie geht es nicht nur darum
er ist auf der suche nach nicht weniger
als dem sinn des lebens
es ist das ist ein gefühl was ich suche
und das ist es auch was die anderen
leute hier suchen hälfte
weiß dass es für manche nomaden und mehr
geht als um sinnsuche für sie ist es die
frage nach dem überleben
diesen leuten will er helfen über seinen
youtube kanal mehr als eine halbe
million abonnenten hat er ist fast schon
eine berühmtheit in der community
userin carroll 50 und single schreibt
sie überlegt ob das nomadenleben etwas
für sie ist
carroll du bist sehr mutig das zu fragen
du solltest stolz auf dich sein
bob macht mut gibt tipps investiert viel
zeit in seine videos und das zahlt sich
aus er verdient gut indem er zum
beispiel werbung auf youtube schaltet
kann sich inzwischen sogar zwei
angestellte leisten
erinnere mich jeden tag daran dass es
jemanden gibt der seine wohnung räumen
muss dieser mensch wird verloren und
hilflos sein und ich habe eine botschaft
für
soziale ungerechtigkeit ist ein thema
das bewegt und der klimawandel vor allem
im moment wo auch diese region hier in
oregon von vielen waldbränden atem
gehalten wird der rauch sichtbar in der
luft hängt
bevor die diese überschwemmungen überall
auf der welt waldbrände und die
erde verändert sich schnell und sie wird
sich in kürze noch viel schneller ändern
und wenn ich in einem fahrzeug bin kann
ich vor den katastrophen einfach
wegfahren
inzwischen könnte sich bob sogar ein
eigenes haus leisten aber das will ja
gar nicht vor 25 jahren fühlte er sich
obdachlos wie ein versager heute nicht
mehr
sicher nicht house los so sagen wir es
gerne es ist ein subtiler unterschied
aber ich denke es ist wichtig ich habe
kein haus aber ich habe ein zuhause und
niemand liebt sein zuhause mehr als ich
ein zuhause auf rädern
bob verlässt den beiden örtlichen oregon
zieht weiter richtung süden
ohne existenzängste kann er inzwischen
die freiheit des nomaden lebens genießen
die freiheit einfach weiterzufahren
[Musik]